des oliviers millénaires des cyprès
toscan de la pierre sèche il ne manque
plus que le chant des cigales dans le
carré méditerranéen de jean mus qui
dessine les plus beaux jardins privés de
la côte d'azur le méridional fait le
pari que toutes ces plantes du sud vont
s'épanouir ici durablement si c'est pour
faire un show pendant l'été c'est pas
notre objectif c'est presque un
laboratoire qui va nous permettre de
vérifier que les pulsions
méditerranéenne qui sont l'âme de ce
jardin pour pouvoir aller jusque sur les
bords de la loire
sur le thème cette année du jardin idéal
les créateurs ont laissé courir leur
imagination
de la convivialité pour le jardin maison
où l'on s'attable comme dans son salon
les couleurs du tissus batiks pour ce
jardin de malaisie
des miroirs dans cet espace vert qui
reflètent le paysage à l'infini et puis
du rouge incandescent pour ses pétales
de fleurs géants destinés à recueillir
l'eau de pluie de la couleur mais aussi
de l'intimité pour l'américaine kathryn
gustafson choisi pour transformer les
jardins du champ de mars à paris
c'est une jardin où je peux me poser
avec un ami de confiance du calme et on
peut se parler donc ça plaît on se parle
seuls 10 des questions très complexes tu
société et sur lesquels on peut pas
parler actuellement cette année le
festival des jardins espère retrouver
son public et se poser en alternative un
contexte social jugées anxiogène et les
jardins ce sont des lieux où se sont
bien ce sont des lieux où on se sent en
accord avec le monde et avec soi même
les jardins nos ressources les jardins
ne recharge et nous permettent d'oublier
par leur poésie valeur beauté toutes les
douleurs du monde nous font oublier le
vide il nous faut oublier l'ukraine le
jardin c'est l'antidote à toutes nos
douleurs
oeuvres d'art potager espaces ludiques
ou thérapeutique le jardin idéal est
celui que nous avons tous dans un petit
coin de notre tête